the white house is gaslighting us they
said our recession is not two negative
gdp quarters what's going on
yeah i mean they seem to be redefining a
lot of definitions uh lately um i think
yeah pure gaslighting um maybe the
technical definition but you ask anybody
on the street ask anybody they they
understand that things aren't as good as
they were last year and by all means
we're uh you know if not technically
we're definitely you know starting uh to
head into recession here i also saw uh
president biden tweeted out saying that
given the uh uh downward price pressure
on gasoline uh the average family saving
35 dollars if they own one car and 70
dollars that they own two
and i died laughing because the first
comment was ramp capital saying how much
do they save if they have three cars
right
it feels like that's what we're dealing
with we're literally dealing with like
elementary math and economics right now
because they just either don't want to
tell us the truth or maybe they don't
understand i don't know
yeah i think it's it's more propaganda
than anything i think that's politics
and and like you know by the way i'm not
like a left or right kind of guy i think
it's just how politics works in general
my general take on it is exactly that
which is like something that used to
just be math is now being uh kind of uh
co-opted by the political uh
administration and it's on both sides of
the aisle right we just had another
president who was doing very similar
things uh and they just continued to try
to twist the data to tell stories about
the stock market the economy whatever uh
it's pretty incredible to watch you have
uh us consumer sentiment and eu consumer
sentiment uh charts stacked on top of
each other
they don't look good
what's going on no
it's it's truly remarkable just uh kind
of the situation we find ourselves in as
a global economy um you know we've been
talking about it you've been talking
about on your show uh for the last year
um but truly it's kind of like the
perfect storm of of just craziness uh
that's that's leading us here right so
uh we have this kind of huge global
asset bubble uh everything bubble that
you know seems to kind of be in the
process of popping that's been happening
for the last uh eight months or so you
know post covet all that stimulus on top
of this uh you have the structural
inflation problem which they were trying
to like if we were if we go back a
little bit they were trying for the
longest time for really almost 20 years
to spur inflation they said inflation's
too low right
cpi was hovering around two percent and
they really they wanted to kick-start
that inflation a little bit um they were
doing quantitative easing they couldn't
do anything to get any inflation i mean
hell the the euro zone had negative
interest rates until just last week for
for about a decade um and so now right
uh post post covet supply chains get
shattered they throw a bunch of funny
money stimulus at everything and now we
get inflation
and that's a good thing for these
actually they were actually rooting for
this inflation why because the debt
loads were so large that they needed a
way to kind of erode the real value of
the debt it was actually a plan if you
read fed papers if you read imf papers
they talked about global debt to gdp
these debt numbers that were
unsustainable and they said how do we
lower them well we can't default
austerity is not politically feasible
well we can run inflation higher than
rates
and higher than and then bond yields for
a while and we can erode that debt so
that was the plan they actually executed
it they did it to get so inflation's too
hot and now due to the kind of the
social push back the political pushback
they're trying to reel it in and the fed
who's way behind the curve is saying all
right i guess we've got to jack up
interest rates so you have consumers
that are that are facing super high
inflation corporate margins are getting
killed
and now they're on top of all this we
have a huge debt problem still and
they're jacking up the cost of capital
so uh obviously not not a good sign i
didn't even mention the russia ukraine
conflict and all the second and third
order effects there um but what a mess
and i think you know we're just kind of
still crazy enough in the early stages
of this uh kind of geopolitical global
uh you know
cluster cluster f
uh when you think about the federal
reserve they were obviously still buying
assets uh and they had interest rates at
zero percent going into the end of the
year inflation was over seven percent
super scary situation in hindsight they
probably shouldn't have been doing that
now we have q1 gdp data negative q2
likely to be negative as well and
they're hiking rates essentially into a
recession are they just repeating the
same mistake but on the other end of the
spectrum
yeah i think the fed is is behind the
curve i mean that's that's kind of an
obvious statement at this point um they
in hindsight shouldn't have been
jacking up uh you know mortgage-backed
securities and treasury bonds into 2021
at a clip of you know 120 billion
dollars a month uh into a into a hot
economy um and they could have honestly
raised that you know those front end
rates uh earlier well obviously that's
in the past can't do anything about it
now so they're very behind the curve
they're actually hiking into a
recessionary period and i think they've
kind of telegraphed that they're doing
this because they're explicitly trying
to crush demand they can't really do
anything on the supply side and honestly
the kind of the paradox here
is that the tightening of monetary
policy actually probably over the medium
to long term
hurts the the supply side dynamics right
we need more supply of energy we need
more supply of commodities
and hiking uh and tightening monetary
policy actually kind of constrains that
effort a little bit so so even if we get
kind of a recession uh we crush demand a
little bit and by we i mean the fed and
global central banks um the kind of the
structural issues here haven't been
fixed and while we do see kind of
year-over-year inflation maybe come down
following these measures uh we still
have a pretty big problem and and you
know if we look big picture here um
stuff like peak globalization is is a is
a pretty big possibility and so if that
is the reality here then then inflation
is is absolutely not going to just you
know return to ho home 2
for the next decade
there's some bigger issues under the
surface